politique bonsoir et bienvenue dans
l'hebdopolitique votre rendez-vous
politique du dimanche soir sur Radio
sensation en association avec tv78
épisode de 227 mon invité ce soir et le
maire de Vélizy-Villacoublay Pascal
thévenou
[Musique]
politique
bonsoir Pascal Thévenot bonsoir vous
êtes mère de Vélizy-Villacoublay vous
faites partie du parti les républicains
et du parti soyons libres le parti de
Valérie Pécresse s'affiliait donc aux
républicains vous êtes maire depuis 2014
et vous avez été élu député en 2016 lors
d'une élection législative partielle un
fauteuil récupéré ensuite par l'actuel
ministre de la transition numérique
Jean-Noël Barraud dernièrement une
nouvelle élection législative partielle
a eu lieu vous vous êtes à nouveau
représenté vous avez été battu au
premier tour en récoltant 17,8% des voix
dans une élection donc marquée par une
très forte abstention 73% au premier
tour et 77% d'abstention au deuxième
est-ce qu'il y a de la déception de voir
que les les habitants ne se sont pas
mobilisés aussi fortement qu'on aurait
pu espérer
alors ça oui c'est toujours une
déception quand il y a beaucoup
d'abstention après sur cette élection
partielle puisque c'était suite à aligné
de Jean-Noël Barrault et sa démission
mais la plus forte déception c'est
plutôt les parties en plus en plus des
voix et
sens commun en fait qui a voulu se
représenter Laurence Trochu et qui était
d'une autre circonscription qui est
venue et qui a fait en fait
l'éparpillements encore plus des voix
sur Versailles qui m'a empêché d'être au
deuxième tour avec un réel choix du coup
des électeurs qui auraient pu avoir lieu
pour 180 voix qui m'a manqué pour être
au second tour et Laurence Trochu a fait
2400 voix sur Versailles quoi et vous
n'êtes donc pas à l'Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui la situation est complexe
pour les républicains coincés entre les
oppositions le RN la nups et la majorité
donc relative présidentielle l'article
49-3 a dû être dégainé trois fois déjà
pour faire passer trois textes
budgétaires cet article donc le 49-3
peut-être utilisé en illimité pour les
taxes budgétaires mais une seule fois
par législature pour tous les autres
projets de loi c'est une méthode
constitutionnelle
mais très décrié d'un point de vue
démocratique à titre personnel vous
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
mais là normalement il est fait pour
pouvoir voter un budget là en fait il la
majorité
présidentielle aujourd'hui s'en sert
pour éviter tout débat en fait
et finalement on verra ce que ça va
donner mais aujourd'hui alors certes les
extrêmes s'agitent aussi avec l'émotion
de censure là la droite le centre
finalement se retrouve
à une position un peu charnière qui fera
que finalement Emmanuel Macron
soit il choisit de rester dans ses
lignes tout en même temps c'est-à-dire
pas grand chose
soit il décide de réformer et
seuls les réformes portées par la droite
qui sont quelque part les réformateurs
par les Français pourront voir le jour
puisque c'est la seule voie qui peut
avoir donc on verra la boîte qui
choisira mais c'est pas une alliance en
fait c'est plus une écoute et le Jupiter
qui doit maintenant changer se
transformer pour devenir un homme qui
écoute qui a pas exactement toujours
raison mais c'est compliqué puisque les
députés aujourd'hui de sa majorité
considèrent que ils ont tout fait ils
ont tout fait bien et que tout ce qui
peut venir d'ailleurs n'est pas
obligatoirement la bonne solution donc
je sais pas comment on va s'en sortir
mais comme vous le dites le 49-3
sur les le budget il peut être utilisé
sur les retraites il pourra pas sur tout
le reste donc il pourra mais une seule
fois une seule fois pendant les cinq ans
par an très bien à la suite de ces
différents donc 49-3 les oppositions ont
déposé plusieurs notions de censure ce
qui sauve entre guillemets le
gouvernement c'est le groupe LR qui ne
l'a pas voté alors finalement et malgré
tout donc et malgré vous aussi tout
repose sur vous sur les républicains
l'expression qui revient c'est que les
LR sont les béquilles de la majorité
est-ce que vous voyez cela
de manière similaire les lerres n'ont
pas voté
là où sont censure parce que toute façon
ça aurait été un chaos et c'est en
changeant le Premier ministre
aujourd'hui qu'on aura obligatoirement
la solution donc et par contre
normalement
s'il y a une construction d'alternative
et bien
l'air pourront aussi voter comme
tous ceux qui se considèrent que la
politique d'Emmanuel Macron n'est pas la
bonne voté une censure là c'est pas et
la béquille non c'est au contraire c'est
ce que je vous disais c'est plus la
charnière puisque aujourd'hui pour avoir
une majorité en dehors du budget mais
pour le mettre en œuvre en fait soit
Emmanuel Macron écoute les propositions
qui sont pas nouvelles de réformes et
attendu encore une fois par le pays pour
s'en sortir aussi dans la stratégie de
l'énergie on voit à quoi ça
la stratégie d'Emmanuel Macron
premierment quinquennat nous amené c'est
la crise en partie aujourd'hui un
l'Ukraine à Bondo mais on en parlera
sûrement mais c'est pas donc là c'est
pas une bêtise c'est plutôt la charnière
donc soit il y a une écoute avec ce qui
est proposé au Sénat ce qui est proposé
Assemblée nationale soit il y a pas
d'écoute et du coup le chaos ça sera ou
la non-réforme on continuera les
non-réformes beaucoup de communication
et des non-réformes telles qu'on les a
vécues pendant 5 ans le président de la
République justement a appelé cette
semaine sur France 2 une alliance avec
les républicains donc pour voter les
textes de loi à l'image de ce que
voudrait l'ancien président Nicolas
Sarkozy
qui souhaite donc un accord quel est
votre position à vous c'est utilisé
cette cette un peu cette place un peu
particulière que les républicains cette
place pivot dans cette Assemblée
nationale pour peser au maximum et donc
aller dans dans les intérêts que vous
vous défendez ou bien ou bien rester nos
positions
franche et sans sans accord
en fait c'est ni l'un Niort c'est
l'alliance en fait elle n'existe pas
puisqu'on n'a pas le même projet on
représente pas les mêmes idées et par
contre ça peut être sur des accords par
rapport en acceptant les amendements les
propositions qui sont faites par les
députés sénateurs du centre mais ça sera
sur chaque projet et à partir du moment
où le gouvernement va dans le bon sens
et accepte nos amendements et nos
propositions de loi et aussi des
propositions qui sont faites et bien on
pourra trouver une majorité de projets
mais aujourd'hui on le voit avec le
Sénat à chaque fois que le Sénat a
proposé des choses et bien elles ont été
toutes remises en cause le plus souvent
par la majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
donc c'est c'est une nouvelle manière de
travailler mais c'est pas des accords
comme il y a pu avoir avec le Front
national aujourd'hui et la majorité
qui donne de quelques vices présidents
et vous êtes gentil on vous
UPS on leur a donné aussi des choses et
les lait aujourd'hui on a été plutôt
considéré comme l'opposition puisque
il a été refusé de donner une
vice-président qui nous permet de
participer au bureau
donc soit voilà aujourd'hui il y a que
le projet mais et puis Nicolas Sarkozy
je reviendrai pas dessus mais Nicolas
Sarkozy fait longtemps qu'il a oublié sa
famille politique et qui s'occupe plus
de ces problèmes personnels tracer le
nouvel voie désigner une nouvelle ligne
politique relancée la dynamique du parti
tel est l'enjeu de la campagne pour la
présidence des républicains le scrutin
est prévu les trois et quatre décembre
prochain sur la ligne de départ on
retrouve Bruno Retailleau sénateur
vendéen
eriksiotti finalise de la primaire et
député des Alpes Maritimes mais Aurélien
Pradier député du Lot alors qui selon
vous est le mieux placé pour prendre les
reines du parti alors les trois ont
des intérêts on participe en fait à la
vie et aux orientations de la droite le
sujet
tel qu'on le vit à l'Assemblée nationale
avec ce côté charnière et cette élection
du président du parti c'est que c'est un
élément de reconstruction on a besoin de
se reconstruire d'avoir une ligne d'être
audible et ce qui nous a manqué le plus
c'est en fait on n'a pas été audible
parce que on n'a pas donné une vision
aux Français de ce que voulait faire la
droite et le centre et il faut qu'on
sorte du catalogue donc là
c'est une bonne occasion d'être entendue
de
porter aussi des réformes après bien sûr
le Président c'est une question après
d'homme il faut choisir
et
Erics ciottis je pense qu'il a fait une
grosse erreur en disant si c'est moi
c'est OK puisque là ça veut dire que bah
déjà je veux ouvrir mais déjà il y a pas
de débat
ça veut dire que tout de suite alors que
on n'a pas de ligne et il faut d'abord
partager une ligne raconter une histoire
et avec les solutions qui peuvent nous
amener à hardric c'est le pays plutôt
que le choix du candidat à la
présidentielle tout de suite donc là
c'est ce qui fait que je peux pas sortir
je le fait de dire si c'est moi c'est ok
peu importe la sympathie qu'on peut
avoir ensemble et tout ça c'est pas
possible pour moi après Aurélien Pradier
à quelques sujets mais on a
il veut ouvrir plutôt sur
des décisions ramener tout au militants
je suis pas sûr que ça soit
obligatoirement l'attente ça
appartiennent il faut qu'on trouve une
ligne et Bruno Retailleau
et pour moi plus dans aussi bien dans la
ligne dans ce qui veut porter et dans ce
qu'il a démontré notamment au Sénat ou
toutes les sensibilités peuvent
s'exprimer et à chaque fois il y a une
unité de vote il y a une synthèse qui
est faite et finalement on arrive à
suivre le cheminement idéologique que
propose la droite et le centre à travers
le Sénat s'il arrive à faire la même
chose au niveau du parti je pense que là
on peut retrouver
une adhésion des Français et une
compréhension surtout sur le projet sur
lequel on veut mener la France donc
plutôt Bruno Retailleau pour vous
qu'est-ce que vous attendez du prochain
président du parti quels sont les
principaux défis et enjeux et vos
attentes allez le défi c'est qu'on
arrive de nouveau à identifier le projet
de la droite du centre et à le partager
avec les Français aujourd'hui on est non
seulement inaudible mais en plus on
a personne peut expliquer où la droite
et le centre veut emmener la France
demain et je pense que Bruno Retailleau
peut à la fois faire une synthèse sur un
programme mais un programme à la fois
pas catalogue mais voilà la France
demain pour nous c'est quoi c'est de la
protection de l'environnement c'est
reconnaître le travail c'est la sécurité
c'est
quoi doit soit attacher le prochain
Président de la République et l'État
avec la décentralisation puisque lui on
a la chance que c'est déjà un élu local
impliqué aussi bien au niveau de la
région au niveau de pas mal de
territoires à travers le sa vision qui
peut avoir à travers le Sénat je pense
que ça peut être une force pour à la
fois renouer avec les Français et les
élus locaux je reviens sur la sur la
volonté d'Eric ceci de désigner Laurent
Wauquiez comme candidat en 2027 sont son
objectif lui c'est d'éviter la caisse
primaire qui ne vous a pas trop réussi
ces dernières années mais pour vous
c'est pas le bon moment c'est beaucoup
trop tôt aujourd'hui de déjà désigner un
candidat pour 2027 peut s'en passer
beaucoup de choses d'ici là oui parce
que je pense qu'en plus
c'est parce que le nom de les Français
c'est
dans presque 5 ans
et l'homme providentiel aujourd'hui on
l'a pas et je pense que les Français
attendent surtout quelqu'un qui pourra
incarner une nouvelle vision qui
pourrait être aussi peut-être une
nouvelle tête
qui partage en fait qui soit plus en
phase avec la tente des Français mais
sur un projet de la droite de droite et
du centre et aujourd'hui oui je pense
que les prix primaires ou pas c'est pas
le bon moment de donner un chef puisque
aujourd'hui ça aurait été bien si on a
eu des époques Chirac il était
incontestable c'était
le chef de partie mais aussi
celui qui menait soit l'opposition sur
la majorité il était un compte testé
Nicolas Sarkozy a pu avoir ce rôle à un
moment aujourd'hui cette personne on l'a
pas donc il faut
l'amener il y en a certains qui
pourraient
il y a David listin qui pourrait avoir
ce rôle mais pareil enfin voilà il y en
a d'autres aussi sûrement mais il faut
qu'on puisse amener ça et arrêter le
débat sur
Laurent Wauquiez pour moi je suis pas
sûr que ça soit celui qui nous fasse
gagner aujourd'hui il pourra peut-être
nous faire gagner demain mais
aujourd'hui on n'a pas cet homme
providentiel donc à partir on n'a pas
d'homme présidentiel on n'aime pas on va
passer tout de suite à la deuxième
partie de l'émission après l'actualité
nationale on va s'intéresser à des
sujets un peu plus locaux
politiques
toujours avec Pascal Thévenot maire de
Vélizy-Villacoublay Comines un peu plus
de 23000 habitants le 11 octobre
l'Association des Maires d'Île-de-France
a publié une lettre à l'attention des
parlementaires francilien dans cette
lettre ils alertent sur le risque de
voir la continuité des services publics
mis en péril en 2023 au moment où les
députés donc des battaient du budget
2023 à l'Assemblée nationale vous avez
vous aussi donc signé ce cri d'alarme la
situation est vraiment préoccupante
aujourd'hui
encore plus critique aujourd'hui avec la
crise énergétique sachant que depuis des
années en fait
on s'est désintéressé des collectivités
locales et on leur a enlevé tout
autonomie fiscale déjà donc en fait
ça fait longtemps qu'on donne l'alerte
sur le fait que le lien direct avec la
population et celui qui permet de
laisser personne de côté c'est avant
tout le maire et par sa proximité donc
là on nous a déjà enlevé toute autonomie
fiscale on nous a fait moi je pars je
prends Visualis en un mandat j'ai perdu
10 millions de DGF j'ai plus de DGF j'ai
une DGF négative donc vous pouvez
préciser dotation globale de
fonctionnement c'est ce que la
participation de l'État à mon budget
donc
se désengagement là il est pas que il
est plutôt général
et là avec la crise de énergie
finalement que l'on subit par des
mauvais souhaits stratégiques par des
mauvais accords et par une crise aussi
internationale finalement on l'a subi
tous et le budget pour certaines
collectivités de l'énergie électricité
gaz c'est le chauffage
plus les augmentations de salaire qui
ont été proposées qui étaient certes
peut-être nécessaire mais pendant les
présidentielle hop c'est check à tout
voir
finalement les seuls économies qu'on
demande c'est aux collectivités les
collectivités doivent avoir un budget
équilibré alors que l'État lui n'a pas
de budget équilibré et ne se
désendettent pas en fait c'est les
collectivités qui participent toujours
des engagements ou des endettements de
l'État donc là on arrive à un moment
ou l'explosion des énergies on est les
seuls à ne pas avoir
j'aime pas le chèque parce que je sais
qu'il faut toujours le payer mais de
mesure qui permettent de
participer d'aider les communes pour
payer leurs énergies et aujourd'hui il
est clair qu'il y a des beaucoup de
villes qui ne peuvent pas équilibrer
leur budget
indépendamment de tout investissement et
du coup ça veut dire que il faudra des
services qui vont fermer des équipements
qui vont devoir fermer et donc et ça
c'est
finalement pas pris en compte c'est
comme si c'était pas grave et les
collectivités on verra vous faire mal
leurs équipements c'est un peu la vision
précédant d'Emmanuel Macron le maire l'a
toujours embêté il aimerait bien qu'on
soit des sous préfets et qu'on exécute
la politique de l'État mais sauf que le
quotidien des gens aussi bien pendant le
covid pour la rentrée pour
les différentes crises qu'on a déjà eu
si on a pu être le tampon de certaines
crises à aider à certaines familles à
pouvoir finir les fins de mois
c'est avant tout les collectivités qui
participent et l'aide sociale c'est soit
le département soit la collectivité mais
c'est beaucoup de départements je vous
propose qu'on écoute là la réaction de
Jean-Michel fourgousse il est présente
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et maire
d'Élancourt sur donc le PLF 2023 et sur
les dotations accordées aux communes
le gouvernement qui est là avec un
budget loi de finance 2023 qui qui
commence à aller pénaliser les
collectivités locales qui elles
participent à l'enrichissement du pays
parti Chypre à la qualité de vie nous on
est on s'occupe on s'occupe des crèches
on s'occupe des écoles on s'occupe des
piscines des théâtres des routes des
seniors même de la police mais pas bon
vous imaginez ce que c'est que d'aller
directement et déjà on a subi des
baisses de moyens on subit aussi les
hausses bien sûr
hors normes de l'énergie et l'État dit
bah tiens on va on va s'en prendre aux
collectivités
on va on va déclarer qu'ils ont des des
réserves déjà c'est extraordinaire on
n'a pas de réserve simplement que les
investissements qu'on n'a pas fait sous
le covid mais bien sûr les amis en
réserve mais on va les faire on est en
train de les faire qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire d'annoncer ça déjà c'est pas très
loyal de faire ça on a besoin de
travailler confiance on a une crise
majeure devant nous il faut il faut bien
sûr être transparent et pas jouer voilà
donc ça ça fait beaucoup les
collectivités qu'on leur parle d'enlever
tel tel recette la compenser par une
autre recette qui est pas fiable qui a
pas la même stabilité en tout cas donc
c'est vrai que les les mers les 12 mers
qui se sont réunis bien sûr tout à
l'heure sont inquiets et en plus ne
peuvent plus préparer
leur budget ne peuvent plus engager de
la même façon un investissement donc ça
veut dire qu'ils vont ralentir
l'investissement c'est les collectivités
locales sont le premier investisseur en
France 70% d'investissement c'est des
collectifs donc et l'emploi qui qui va
avec donc on va ils vont ils vont on va
ralentir les ou bloquer ne pas faire les
investissements prévus
ne pas construire les logements prévus
ne pas bien sûr construire les
équipements prévus
donc vous vous imaginez les ou
l'entretien du bâtiment si on veut pas
baisser les bâtiments passoires que l'on
attend mais oui ça coûte on peut pas et
nous on va dans le bon sens et puis et
puis attirer les entreprises on sait on
développe on fait du développement
économique ici on va chercher des
entreprises on les accompagne on les
installe on installe leur salarié dans
les meilleures conditions vous voyez
allez toucher à ça cela vous allez
toucher à la production de richesse
Jean-Michel fourgousse au micro de
Jessie Willens est-ce que dans d'autres
villes vous avez du coup était impactés
ce que vous avez déjà estimé le manque à
gagner avec cette inflation et est-ce
que vous avez bouclé votre budget pour
une prochaine alors c'est pas un manque
à gagner
c'est des charges supplémentaires
parce que je disais la même chose c'est
ce que ce que dit Jean-Michel avec aussi
la masse salariale qui est subie puisque
le gouvernement a décidé d'augmenter le
point à décider moi quand masse
salariale j'ai pris un million de
supplémentaires simplement avec les
mesures décidées par le gouvernement
donc c'est énorme donc c'est plutôt des
charges supplémentaires c'est pas ça
revient à déséquilibre du budget et
aujourd'hui moi alors j'ai de la chance
parce que je vais dire avait toujours
été un peu vertueux et en avant-garde
même avant moi depuis sa construction
sur les isolations au niveau de la
pression de l'environnement au niveau du
chauffage urbain une chose comme ça donc
là moi la chance que j'ai c'est que j'ai
parié sur de la géothermie profonde
que j'ai mis en service dans des buts
d'années et qui du coup
moins dépendant du maître de chauffer
tous mes équipements publics et tous les
logements collectifs de la ville c'est
l'équivalent 12000 logements en
géothermie et avec un cas de grand froid
un apport de gaz mais ça me limite ma
facture
le chauffage urbain c'est un million
deux au niveau du budget donc s'il a été
multiplié par 7 vous imaginez que je
serai en grande difficulté là il va
augmenter de 20% parce qu'il y a une
part de gaz il y a aussi de
l'électricité un peu mais globalement je
ça je suis protégé de ça après il me
reste l'électricité où on a déjà fait
beaucoup d'investissement sur
l'éclairage public donc finalement les
économies sont déjà faites mais c'est un
million cinq
le coût de l'électricité sur la ville
cette fois
et la part de l'éclairage public c'est
300000 euros donc finalement même si on
va l'éteindre la nuit c'est pas là que
je vais gagner le plus il faut que je
fasse des économies
sur les la consommation électrique des
équipements de la ville donc là
finalement pour tout ça et pour
équilibrer le fonctionnement
là je vais j'ai une crèche qui va ou qui
devait ouvrir un début janvier et je
vais la décaler en septembre ce qui me
permettra de retrouver
quelques facilités un budgétaire pour
équilibrer mon budget de fonctionnement
et
un pouvoir gérer des hausses qu'on ne
connaît pas obligatoirement et qui
pourrait arriver encore sur 2023 donc là
je vais mais j'ai j'achète son chemin et
j'ai aussi la chance d'avoir une zone
d'activité dynamique
sur laquelle j'investis beaucoup un ou
qui prend une bonne part de des
investissements de la ville aussi bien
pour aller chercher les entreprises pour
les accompagner et cette dynamique fait
que je conserve une dynamique aussi de
mon budget et ce qui me permet de
d'arriver à l'équilibrer mais on va
chasse au gaspille on l'avait déjà fait
avant et là on accélère le plan de qui
était plutôt pas pour des économies
budgétaires mais pour protéger notre
environnement et qui finalement là se
traduit aussi par des économies
budgétaires donc on va l'accélérer mais
oui non ça a été
chaque dépense a été vu et
je demande à tous les acteurs aussi bien
les habitants que les collaborateurs de
la ville de faire attention à
l'extinction des ordinateurs
en partant à l'extinction des lumières
la baisse de l'intensité dans un gymnase
si vous avez vous n'êtes pas en
compétition finalement on a peut-être
pas besoin
du même taux d'éclairement quand on est
en match et quand on s'entraîne parce
que de toute façon
il faut ce sont des économies qui me
permettront de boucler le budget et
d'investir demain mais moi j'ai cette
chance là après si vous ce compte pas eu
la chance ou pas eu l'opportunité aussi
d'avoir du chauffage qui soit pas au gaz
j'ai quand même encore deux écoles qui
sont gaz c'est des vieilles écoles
celle-ci et on baisse la température
mais même ça ça
sans mesure parce que ça s'est subi
c'est
la baisse du passé à 50% de nucléaires
ah un impact fort sur le coût d'énergie
puisque le nucléaire a pas bougé donc là
c'est une stratégie quand on voit ce que
c'est pas mal les émissions de radio
mais non sont tout enregistrées donc
quand on entend le président de la
République à tout le monde l'Europe est
à 50% nucléaire ça fonctionne bien il y
aura jamais de problème on le paye
lourdement aujourd'hui et puis en plus
des accords
sur une péréquation avec le coup pour le
coup de l'énergie l'électricité soit la
même surtout en Europe finalement on
paye aussi les mauvais choix de
l'Allemagne et on a un président de la
République qui a signé c'est des accords
qui font que même si notre énergie
nucléaire qui nous reste ne coûte pas
plus cher on l'appelle quand même
beaucoup plus cher pour compenser
les mauvais choix stratégiques avec du
charbon et en Allemagne donc là il y a
un moment la stratégie l'État doit être
responsable et c'est là qui doit
participer pour que tous les acteurs en
fait en faisant des économies dans son
budget parce que son budget et les
économies budget de l'État il y a des
choix qui doit faire il y a peut-être
des commissions qui doit moins ouvrir à
chaque fois on ouvre une commission
Haddock on ouvre sur même pas des
cabinets
donc c'est l'État qui doit faire les
économies les collectivités les ont déjà
fait depuis très longtemps et sont à
l'équilibre et on suivra la situation
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes le maire de
Vélizy-Villacoublay et nous on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de politique sur Radio
sensation
[Musique]